vsauce kevin here with 45 chicken
nuggets
63 cents and 130 years of
algorithmic evolution that means you
wait as little time as possible
in the checkout lane at the grocery
store almost
you've been grinding in the mine all day
with your pickaxe swinging from side
to side and the only thing that you
value right now
more than diamonds is a box full of
sweet chicken nuggets
and some delectable tangy dipping sauce
your mom says that she'll get you as
many nuggets as you want but
you want to make things a little
difficult for her because she canceled
your realm subscription so
you ask her to order the largest number
of nuggets that
due to available nugget configurations
is impossible
for her to get which means that your new
best friend
is german mathematician ferdinand
frobenius
in his late 1800s lectures frobenius
toyed with a thought experiment
that would change how we think about
nuggets forever
the premise is simple what's the largest
integer that cannot be expressed as a
combination of integers
with the greatest common divisor of one
told you it was simple
the answer is the frobenius
number let me explain let's say
hypothetically that nuggets only come in
fives and nines their greatest common
divisor is
one if they only come in groups of fives
or
nines and there are all sorts of small
nugget orders you just can't make by
combining them like 7 11
or 16. you can work out a table of
possible combinations but
in 1882 english mathematician j.j
sylvester who
was so important to developing how we
think and
talk about math that he coined basic
terms like
matrix and graph came up with a simple
formula to find the biggest number you
can't make
from two numbers that have a greatest
common divisor of one
x times y minus x minus
y so let's just plug in our five and r
nine
five times nine minus five minus nine
equals
thirty-one there's our nugget frobenius
because look 32 is possible that's just
9 plus 9 plus 9 plus
5 so is 33 9 plus 9 plus 5
plus 5 plus 5 equals 33 so is 34
9 plus 5 plus 5 plus 5 plus 5
plus 5 equals 34. and so
is every other number after the
frobenius
having a greatest common divisor of 1 is
key here because if the greatest comet
divisor is higher like
two there can't be a frobenius number
at all and the proof of that is in
the nuggets in the u.s mcdonald's only
sells nuggets in boxes of 4
6 10 and 20. because the greatest common
divisor is
2 any odd number very small or
very large presents an impossible
ordering combination
in america you just can't order seven
or seventy three million two hundred
twelve thousand nine hundred
seven nuggets no but as brady heron of
numberphile showed in 2012 the nugget
situation is more complex in the united
kingdom
since mcdonald's in the uk surfed
nuggets in quantities of 6
9 and 20 brady was able to stump the
cashier
with an order of 43 nuggets
the highest possible combination of 6
9 and 20 that mcdonald's couldn't
possibly make
because check it out you can make 42
nuggets because
6 times 7 equals 42. you can make 44
with 20 plus 9 plus 9 plus 6
but no combination of 6 9 and
20 will get you 43 however you can make
every number after 43. you can't make 37
34 31 28 or 25 either but
43 is the highest number you can't
make you can work out all the
possibilities for three
values of mcnuggets by hand and it
doesn't take
too long but while there is a formula we
used earlier to find the frobenius with
those two numbers there's no simple
formula for three
variables or four or forty four or seven
thousand two hundred
eighteen there's just an algorithm that
ranges from tedious to
requiring a super computer but
who cares about chicken nugget
combinations
is it really that important to annoy
someone in a mcdonald's half hour
outside of barton in the beans or
to get your mom back for canceling
realms no
but it matters to anyone who uses
money like everyone everywhere
in the world the concepts that frobenius
and sylvester tackled
are really about mathematical
optimization what can you do with a
given set of numbers and
how easily can you do it that's at the
heart of how we use
coins and decide on their denominations
under our current systems in places like
the us and the eu
we're greedy when we make change
literally
we use what's called a greedy algorithm
to
process transactions it's a crude common
sense way of
approaching change
basically we select the biggest
denominations of coins to get close to a
number without going over
then the next biggest and then the next
until we have the amount
that we need in the u.s our common coins
are
.01 0.05 0.1
and 0.25 a penny a nickel a dime and a
quarter so to get to 63 cents we'd
select
two quarters one dime and three pennies
that's 63 cents that seems like it has
to be the best possible way with the
best
possible numbers but are they really the
optimal denominations
in 2003 computer scientist jeffrey
shallot put it
to the test he found that in the 1 5 10
25 american system the average number of
coins given as
change in a transaction was 4.7
but by removing the 10 cent piece and
replacing it with an 18 cent piece
charlotte found that optimization
increased markedly to just
3.89 coins per transaction
knowing that removing a simple coin like
a dime surely wouldn't be popular he
then wondered what
additional denomination would simplify
transactions
and he found that adding a 32 cent piece
would reduce the average
transaction down to 3.46
coins for the canadian system
charlotte's addition of an
83 cent piece would reduce the average
transaction by
about a coin and a half but how easily
can we even
think about the world in terms of 83s
and
18s and how difficult is it not to be
greedy if we had an 18 cent coin the
best way to make 54 cents in change
would be
three 18s and not our go-to
greedy mindset of two quarters and four
pennies
by employing charlotte's optimal
denominations we'd
cut the number of coins in that
transaction
by half but how
natural would that be is it possible
that being
inefficient mathematically can be more
efficient in real life yes
if you want to get wacky with me it's
possible to ensure that
every single change transaction between
1
and 100 cents uses no more than just
two coins seriously you just need
denominations of 1 3
4 9 11 16 20 25 30 34 39 41 46 47
49 and 50. with those you can make
change for anything with some
combination
of just two coins but instead of dealing
with
four common types of coins in the us
you'd be dealing with
16 that have no obvious rhyme or reason
for their
denominations we even used to have a
more mathematically
optimized coin system but rolled it back
for simplicity's sake
the us used a two cent piece between
1864 and 1873
and even had three cent pieces between
1851 and 1889
charlotte's calculations show that the
presence of a two or
three cent piece reduces the average
coins in a transaction
by 0.8 it turns out that having to
calculate with extra denominations is
more inconvenient than carrying around
some
additional pennies with fewer
coin types you're not fumbling around
looking for
specific coins and holding up the
checkout line
at the grocery store it turns out that
sometimes what's best for math
isn't best for everyday life
in 1870 french military engineer
charles renard proposed a series of
preferred numbers for the world to use
with
well nearly everything the idea was that
simple systems could streamline how we
think about the world and
a rough rounded variation of renard's r3
shows up in the one two five system of
currencies in europe and china while the
us
and canada use a modified one two five
is that heuristic a basic set of rules
to help us
process our numerical world the
mathematically
optimal way to do everything
well no it isn't it's
pretty good but it's not the best
possible result in terms of math it's
just the
best possible result in terms of people
in most of my videos i like to extract
the hidden mathematical beauty in
everyday life
but for this one it turned out to
kind of be the opposite perfectly
optimal algorithms don't
always play nicely with how our brains
work and
how we live our lives there are
practical limits to how we can
apply our advancing mathematical
knowledge to our
daily lives and that's okay
because whether it's nugget boxes or
pockets full of coins what's best
mathematically may not necessarily be
best
for the human experience
unless you really really really want
43 chicken nuggets and as always thanks
for watching